On the same day as the attack on Pearl Harbor,
Japan carried out a combined attack against
Hong Kong, the Philippines, Thailand and Malaysia.
That day was December 7th, 1941.
After taking control of Hong Kong, the Japanese
army imprisoned the colony’s administrators
and many British and American citizens in
prison camps, replaced the Hong Kong dollar
with the military Yen and confiscated all
of the city’s manufacturing and commercial
facilities.
During the four years of Japanese occupation,
Hong Kong’s economy plummeted so low it
was virtually ruined and the population was
reduced by half.
But finally on August 15th, 1945, after the
harsh Pacific War, the Second World War ended.
Japan surrendered and Hong Kong was returned
to the British.
From that moment on, a new story began.
It was a time for economic takeoff.
A process that would transform this city into
one of the freest and richest territories
in all of Asia and, indeed, the entire planet.
With seven and a half million inhabitants
and more than 1,200 skyscrapers, Hong Kong
has been the great benchmark of almost the
entire Asian continent for the past couple
of decades.
However, this is changing.
You see, located in the middle of the Pearl
River delta, China’s great technological
and industrial area, is the city of Shenzhen.
In 2018, Hong Kong saw its neighbor, Shenzhen
– known as the Chinese Silicon Valley – snatch
first place as the city with the largest economy
in southern China.
That's right, Hong Kong is no longer the biggest
economy of the cities that make up the Pearl
River delta.
But, this has a small caveat.
Shenzhen has just over ten million inhabitants,
which is three to five million more than Hong
Kong, so in terms of wealth per capita, Hong
Kong is still much richer.
But, that’s beside the point because what
this shows us is that things are changing,
and Hong Kong is falling behind.
And that doesn’t mean to say that the city’s
economy isn’t growing.
Just that Hong Kong’s neighbors are growing
at a faster rate.
That and the fact that while its neighbors,
particularly Shenzhen, have become important
technological and industrial centers, from
which multinationals as influential as Tencent,
DJI or Huawei have emerged, Hong Kong is only
significant as a financial center... and nothing
more.
And the question that more and more people
are asking themselves today is, is this a
sign of Hong Kong’s decline or rebirth?
Yes, you heard that correctly.
It’s black or white.
Listen up.
THE CITY OF CONTRASTS)
Folks, it’s your turn for a question.
Are you ready?
Which city do you think has the most ultra-rich
people living in it?
The city with the highest number of people
with assets worth $30 million or more?
I’m guessing many of you thought of New
York, London or perhaps Dubai, right?
Well... cold, cold.
Freezing!
New York eclipsed as city with most extremely
wealthy people.
Hong Kong is now home to more extremely rich
people than any other city in the world.
Washington Post)
Yes, Hong Kong.
Hong Kong, is the city with the most billionaires
on the planet right now.
More than 10,000 residents in this city have
a portfolio worth more than $30 million.
What do you think of that?
So you may be thinking... well… if the city’s
growing at around 3% per year and it’s the
city with the most billionaires in the world...
then things are going really well, right?
Well yes... and no.
Folks, Hong Kong is a paradox.
See, on the one hand we have an apparently
thriving and prosperous city.
A modern and influential financial center.
To give you an idea, Hong Kong’s Stock Exchange
is huge.
It lists more than 2,300 companies with a
total market value of just over $4.1 trillion.
However, at the same time, this city has loads
of problems.
The poorest residents are earning progressively
less and less money, infant mortality rates
are rising, the population is aging rapidly
and a huge percentage of the population lives
in housing that falls well short of building
standards in any developed country.
In many cases these are tiny spaces that don’t
even have windows or ventilation.
These could truly be described as holes.
Folks, the most claustrophobic living spaces
in the world can be found in this city.
And this has a lot to do with the fact that
what should be a well-off middle class, really
isn’t.
Nearly half of Hong Kong flats rent for US$2,550
a month – 70 per cent of median household
income.
SCPM)
According to research company Demographia,
housing prices are 20.9 times higher than
the average household's annual income in Hong
Kong, compared with 3.9 times in the U.S.
and 4.3 times in Canada.
TAKESHI KIHARA, Nikkei Asian Review staff
writer)
But, folks, we already talked about Hong Kong’s
housing situation in a previous video, which
I’ll link in the description.
And before you jump the gun, I can already
tell you that this has nothing to do with
capitalism gone wild, or corporate greed,
or overpopulation, or anything like that .
In this case it’s actually the government
who is to blame, because in Hong Kong the
vast majority of the land and a good part
of the houses belong to the government, they
are all public.
But don’t think that’s the end of it,
there’s much, much more.
In October 2018, the investment bank Nomura
presented a report warning that the likelihood
that Hong Kong may suffer a financial crisis
in the coming years has soared.
“Hong Kong sits in the 'danger zone' for
a fresh financial crisis” Business Insider)
One of the main reasons for this is that a
good part of the population has taken huge
loans to buy a home.
Therefore, a very high percentage of Hong
Kong residents, particularly young professionals,
are up to their necks in mortgage debt.
Hong Kong has very large credit and property
market overhangs.
Since 2008, real property prices have risen
125% and the ratio of private non-financial
credit to GDP has surged to 299%.
Nomura)
And if we add the fact that wages haven’t
increased and that the economy depends greatly
on China, whose own growth seems to be slowing
down, this could be a recipe for disaster.
"I want to leave because Hong Kong is no longer
what it used to be.
My plan is to get a master's degree in Canada,
find a job, and start a new life”.Jonathan
Chan, a 24-year-old Hong Kong student.)
Because of course… killing yourself working
endless days, to live in a tiny house for
which, you pay a huge mortgage, leaving you
very little disposable income… it doesn’t
really make you feel very optimistic.
Don’t you agree?
And then on top of that you can’t set up
anything on your own because commercial space
is also very expensive, which makes matters
even worse.
Well, that's precisely what more and more
young Hong Kong people think...
Check this out.
“According to a 2018 survey by the Chinese
University of Hong Kong, 51% of people between
the ages of 18 and 30 said they are thinking
about leaving the territory”.
TAKESHI KIHARA, Nikkei staff writer)
More than half of the younger population want
to live somewhere else.
Don’t tell me that that isn’t worrisome.
And then we need to take into account China’s
increasing political interference and the
growing restrictions on political freedoms:
Hong Kong bans pro-independence party as China
tightens grip.
Hong Kong National Party banned in the interests
of ‘national safety’.
The Guardian)
Hong Kong press freedom in question as FT
journalist denied visa.
Hong Kong has refused to renew a work visa
for the Asia news editor of the Financial
Times.
Reuters)
As you can see, it wouldn’t be unreasonable
to say that we’re facing something like
the decline of Hong Kong’s splendor, that
city, folks, which dazzled the world by becoming
a financial, commercial, and cultural center…
For decades Hong Kong had the third largest
film industry in the world.
An industry that was thought could rival even
Hollywood itself.
But hang on just a second… because some
argue that... yes all this has happened, but
now the city is about to experience a rebirth.
So are Hong Kong's best days yet to come?
(THE NEW CHINESE HONG KONG)
We’ve already told you here on VisualPolitik:
the Chinese president doesn’t really like
this whole one country two systems thing.
Xi Jinping is determined to reduce Hong Kong’s
political autonomy.
Well, to achieve this he has presented a great
plan: the Great Bay metropolitan area project.
See, the Chinese president wants to turn the
entire Pearl River delta, where cities such
as Hong Kong, Macao, Shenzhen or Guangzhou
are located, into a large metropolitan area
that is perfectly interconnected and has immense
economic integration.
And we are talking about more than 70 million
people and a GDP that in 2030, according to
Morgan Stanley estimates, will be over three
trillion dollars.
That’s larger than the UK’s economy.
So far, the big infrastructure projects are
already a reality: a high-speed train has
been inaugurated between Hong Kong, Shenzhen
and Guangzhou, and also the longest bridge
in the world now connects Hong Kong and Macao.
A connection that is no less than 55 km long,
and which, understandably, cost a fortune.
The problem?
The Chinese government wants all this integration
to end Hong Kong’s autonomy.
And among other things, although they are
formally a single country, regulations, laws
and courts are different in Hong Kong than
in mainland China There are even borders and
customs between the two territories…
So in order to make the metropolitan area
really work, some harmonization would have
to take place... which of course means that
Hong Kong would become increasingly Chinese
and that when its autonomy agreement expires
in 2047, it wouldn’t be renewed without
strict conditions.
Do you see it now?
Well, there's more.
In a spectacular turn of events, China has
appointed Hong Kong as the National Center
for Technology and Innovation in southern
China.
For the first time, the Chinese government
has begun financing research projects in Hong
Kong’s universities, has demanded the government
enforce a doubling of research and development
budgets and approves a program to attract
scientists and technologists from all over
the world.
But...
Why would China do this?
Well folks, because Hong Kong has a huge advantage
over the rest of the Asian continent: it’s
considered a market economy and isn’t subject
to import restrictions.
That is, Hong Kong companies can buy whatever
they want, including high-tech goods that
can have both civilian and military applications,
products that the government and Chinese companies
cannot buy.
In other words, China wants to take advantage
of Hong Kong's status to boost its technological
development plans.
If it succeeds, that’ll be great for China
and Hong Kong.But even if that plan is thwarted,
China will still get the upper hand with Hong
Kong.
Consider this; if the United States and the
rest of the other Western powers impose restrictions
on Hong Kong and end their free port status,
this will push the city even more into China’s
hands, who will be happy to invest billions
in this territory in exchange for full control.
Anyway, folks, now you see.
It’s hard to predict if we’re facing Hong
Kong’s decline or rebirth, but what does
seem clear, is that Hong Kong will become
more and more Chinese.
But now it's your turn, do you think Hong
Kong will see a return to its golden days?